bio tout le monde sait ce quiz ya
quelques jours se trouve sur happy with
comme l'indiquent cette grosse femme
moche elle c'est parti sur quel niveau
va se rendre en premier crime city
les contrôles ne marche pas très bien le
ridicule à l'état pur j'arrive là j'ai
pris le perso le plus what à dieu je
t'abandonne jeter mais trop d'émotion à
ok d'ailleurs petite heure pour y
laisser faire on a vu mon vieux qu'eux
qui dépassait de la maison là la seule
chose que je voulais faire de ma vie
c'est de me mettre en position foetale
et moi je suis seul au milieu de la
forêt voilà je bronze
je m'en fous je suis bien je touche
descend imaginaire ça me plaît
maintenant on fait la position de
l'araignée comme quand j'étais petit au
judo puis là on va tenter le backflip up
attendant la maison s'en remet à la
maison voilà parfait ok tout va bien
mais il est attention sauvetage merde je
suis désolé salut je m'en fous je me
suis fait un nouvel ami ça va mais c'est
le canard moi ça va
webcam et c'est quoi les sauces à bastia
cheval je vous prie de battante s'il
vous plaît est ce que c'est vraiment
sérieux de faire un niveau comme ça mais
ce cheval je suis une position délicate
actuellement sur votre dos non non pas
les fesses pas à monsieur le cheval
comment vous expliquer actuellement
c'est plutôt érotique entre nous
monsieur cheval je vous a plu oh [ __ ]
de cheval
ok ok y'a pas toi mais c'est instantané
quoi c'est la mort instantanée lui la
boîte c'est parti
le hic à l'arrière il était carrément
dans le mal qu r&d bien le mec à
l'arrière il a pas mis sa ceinture
ah oui non non quand même pas qu'est ce
qui se passe à la vente de cette voiture
là haut est ce que j en train de montrer
mes fesses à toutes les personnes qui
seraient dans le sens contraire de la
route
au regard des gens sur place tu vas te
prendre mon poing dans top dead
non non afida pendant un mois je me suis
dit est-ce que je vais vivre watts
salut mes fesses cette position est
délicate à l'aller pas s'y passe ipass
bons fous ils passent je suis libre
c'est parti waouh attendait mais ils
sont bien trop lourd les sables quoi
t'en tiens abdominaux au plus tard à je
sais pas est ce qu'on me pardonne
voilà allez fallait pas toucher mon
chien meurt
voilà comme ça il m'a pris tout mon
argent est ce que je te pardonne mais
regardez il n'y a pas été foutu de
s'acheter des bons freins ol laisser
vivre roman purge stock vélo attention
si tu ne remonte pas je viens avec toi
fiston ya comme un vélo entre nous
j'arrive de la manière la plus ridicule
mais c'est pas grave arpan douanes c'est
parti allez fitou accroche-toi a fist au
plus tôt attention piwigo au nom ce
temps le val de small au salut qu'est ce
qu'on fait au pique nique à je suis dans
les fesses en l'air
l'humiliation la plus totale wathier
qu'est ce qui est arrivé à ce petit jeu
c'est ça veut dire de me dire au revoir
c'est lors de son ami discrètement au
lof et ce taux c'est pas grave je
continue de pédaler à les fils tôt ah
c'est pas comme s'il y avait le poids de
tout quatre personnes sur toi c'est le
niveau de la femme nue voilà un
non
e
ok c'était le niveau de la femme nue
c'était très intense et très nul 1-1 au
racing mais qu'est ce sont les gens qui
font des niveaux comme ça [ __ ] moi
j'aime bien en fait me mettre en
position foetale comme ça je peux faire
des pompes sur toi papa d'amy lee ou ap
je suis en vacances au milieu de plein
de boules et j'aimerais bien être des
coincés
miley pourquoi je fais ça va il est
comment ça va non non tu roman mon fils
m'a il est que je suis accroché à la
boule de pâte et cyrus et je me touchent
les tétons comme ça oui c'est vrai ça
j'adore la scène la plus ridicule du
monde au maire d' nom ne te soucie pas
de moi tu es bouteille avant ouais un
beau jour où et c'est là que la vie du
monsieur à l'hélicoptère sachets va mais
là c'est moi vivre gp délit ce qu'on
voulait jah gao voilà ok bah je reste
entre de cadeaux voilà je suis condamné
et je m'en fous parce que je peux
m'allonger et dire bonjour à mes pieds
allez allez allez les filles à on [ __ ]
à aller aller au pénal toujours ma fille
quoi qu'il arrive ça lui le bébé tiens
bon bah écoute tu peux te faire une amie
voilà je te la présenta les ailes
t'invite à aller dans ses bras voilà
comme ça ta lettre tu as l'air vraiment
content dit donc et le maul ce poste
ok date fait il bon gars jouent du apple
as fait ça ça va être sympa ça ok ce que
j'aimerais pas accomplir s'ils avaient
une pomme sur la tête
non j'ai la pièce à bercy petit bébé un
qui vient de montrer ses jolies fesses
pas ouais ok on a avec yvon jus de
pastèque d'en publier votre problème
c'est ma petite technique faut pas
prendre trop de kilos la pastèque et
fiston j'ai une surprise pour toi
what you [ __ ] d'asticots sur un vélo
oh mon dieu
hello i'm buckley welcome to the death
tarn
ah bah merci c'est un accueil chaleureux
un merci beaucoup
ok mais peut-être qu'ils pètent à la
pesée et fiscales ça va arriver mon
chéri peut-être pape
l'estivage de fès dans l'air las
n'importe quoi ok oh mon mari steak
[ __ ] je vais y arriver
o comme ça puisqu'on a disparu what
c'est pas grave c'est quoi cette jambe
oh [ __ ] olaj hommes qui pédalent et de
la manière la plus ridicule à terre dont
il est trop gros ils rentrent pas dans
le voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de
ce petit best of sur un pee wee j'espère
que ça vous aura plu l'impasse qu'en
tout cas moi je me suis personnellement
bien marré a apprécié son seul c'est un
peu dommage
je vous souhaite un [ __ ] de bon
week-end plein de sortie dans le froid
ou alors de guidage au chaud et puis on
se retrouve dimanche soir dans une
nouvelle vidéo tu as tout le monde pis à
bientôt